here first on the legal side of all this
reaction to today's ruling and what it
means fox news legal analyst greg
jarrett harvard law professor uh alan
dershowitz is with us all right let's
talk about this 6-3 decision uh
professor i'll start with you
and you must show proper cause i thought
justice uh thomas writing for the
majority kind of nailed it there's no
other constitutional right where you
have to show
just cause or proper cause
well the new york state law was very
broad and very vague if you read the
majority decision together with the
concurring opinion of justice kavanaugh
who helped form the majority it was four
votes and then kavanaugh and and roberts
comprise the six and then the three
dissenters
kavanaugh says this doesn't stop a state
from requiring registration uh
background checks uh how old you have to
be
what kinds of guns so
it doesn't tell us very much about
whether states can pass laws restricting
ak-15s
or requiring people to be 21 instead of
18 we're going to have to wait to see in
subsequent decisions whether or not the
thrust of the majority which is what
exactly the way you described it or the
concurring opinions limitations on the
majority ultimately become the law it's
a it's a work in progress you know greg
if you're talking about the right to
carry we're not talking about carrying
um uh an ar-15 it would normally be a
revolver it would be a pistol nine
millimeter or 40 whatever it happens to
be
uh small compact for protection uh
that that seems pretty obvious to me but
i wouldn't doubt that the state
legislature in a liberal state like new
york tries to work around this decision
probably almost immediately you concur
oh they probably will they no doubt will
um
the people who voiced utter shock and
disbelief at today's decision are either
clueless or they weren't paying
attention this was foreseeable it was
predictable because it was consistent
with the prior supreme court decisions
justice thomas waited until page 62
to point out that the second amendment
isn't a second-class right and over on
cnn i was amazed and amused to watch
legal analyst jeffrey tuvan throw a
hissy fit as if that's some new and
novel concept if jeff had actually read
the decision he would have noticed that
thomas's statement was in quotes where
did it come from it came from the last
major supreme court decision 12 years
ago which tubin either didn't read or he
didn't remember
he also became unglued
saying that conservatives want no rules
no regulations it's going to be a
free-for-all as if the supreme court
would abide by that no the supreme court
in the heller decision stated very
clearly that reasonable restrictions are
permissible and indeed the court then
identified several restrictions that
were perfectly okay so we will have to
wait and see whether things like
background checks and red flag laws with
due process are permissible but i
suspect those things would be
professor does this immediately negate
the current law in new york in other
words would people in new york now have
the ability to apply for a carry
concealed carry permit and be granted it
and not have to prove proper cause
yes uh i think that's right i think the
new york law has been struck down but
there will be attempts by new york as
greg says to
adapt to the heller decision and to this
decision and to permit some kinds of
regulations remember that the second
amendment talks about a well-regulated
militia and militias at the time of the
framing were well regulated by the
states and so the states still reserve
to themselves residual power to do
reasonable regulations what the court
said today is that new york's regulation
was not reasonable because it gives too
much discretion to administrators to
determine what constitutes good cause if
you feel frightened if you've had a
subjective experience you can't get a
permit in new york you have to show that
you've actually been threatened and new
york permits have been very very hard to
get and so i think what the court is
saying is if new york wants to tighten
up its law and make it more objective
that was the word used by justice
cavanaugh over and over again so
kavanaugh's concurring opinion with
roberts is an invitation to the states
to do better whereas i think justice
thomas's decision set out a framework
for analysis which suggests that not all
efforts to
tighten up the laws will be accepted
back
in progress let me go back to the the
point that you were making about a
well-regulated militia our own
government at the time defined the
militia as
as the people as a whole that's how it
was defined by the government
but it was states remember there was a
big fight between hamilton and jefferson
about whether there should be a standing
army and the second amendment was part
of a compromise to give the role of the
armed forces over to state militias so
states do have some power and you know
under our system of checks and balances
and federalism you're never going to get
a perfect solution there's always going
to have to be a balance struck between
state and federal between the judiciary
and the legislature and we're going to
see this work its way out over the next
probably decade i will give you the last
word greg jarrett
yeah look the um
the states and the founders intended
that the bill of rights every single one
of them all 10 of them the primary be
fundamental rights that's how it was
ratified the trouble with the new york
law is it shifted
the presumption and the burden to the
citizen to prove they had that right
that is inherently wrong according to
our constitutional interpretation of the
second amendment and the bill of rights
all right greg jarrett thank you
professor always good to have you as
well thank you